[Musique]
donc ce qui est bien une pâle et en
dernier c'est que j'ai eu la chance et
l'honneur d'écouter tout le monde dans
une salle aussi impressionnante qui s'y
est de retenir les bonnes leçons et les
bons tuyaux c'est respirer
j'ai écouté de la musique ça m'a détendu
tout ça c'est plus facile maintenant et
donc je voulais vous dire deux choses
mon métier me motiver chez les rêves
la première je viens du nil je viens de
l'île maurice et vous pensez aux places
mais moi je regardais de la plage la
mère enfant et je me disais mais qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière pour nous c'est
l'horizon et derrière c'est l'inconnu
premier 1er premier moment le 2ieme qui
suis exactement parce que on est un pays
d'immigrants y avait personne avant et
je suis métisse de tous qui vient de
partout et de nulle part en même temps
je retrouvais le mot passerelle de soria
dans ma démarche est mon fils m'a poussé
notre unique fils à faire un test adn
et quand j'ai reçu les résultats j'avais
une carte du monde et donc ça a renforcé
ce besoin de découvrir l'inconnu de
découvrir l'ailleurs c'est devenu un
rêve qu'on lisait
les marco polo les bandes dessinées de
marco polo
c'était un rêve et ce rêve de les
réaliser en 2011 avec mon fils
encouragées par ma femme qui est là ici
il m'a dit si tu le fais pas tu ne feras
jamais effectivement sans grande
préparation on est parti il ya une
dizaine d'années dix-huit mille
kilomètres d'istanbul en chine par
grande préparation des amis qui venaient
me voir une dernière fois pour différer
et j'espère que tu reviendras et rené
partie et on est parti dans les endroits
les plus improbables par la route les
moyens du bord les bus les marches ou de
calais les traits des chameaux les
chevaux enfin tout ce qui était possible
et imaginable
on l'a fait ensemble et on a découvert
des peuples on à découvrir les peuples
et pour moi c'était une double
découverte j'ai aussi découvert mon fils
vivent ensemble 24h 24 pendant 18 km 18
mille kilomètres et pendant 90 jours
non-stop et donc c'est ça qui m'a permis
de voir et de dire que en fait le monde
ne va pas si mal que ça seulement on le
voit autrement et je vais partager avec
vous ce que j'ai vu et c'est que mon
père il est complice de partout dans
tous ces pays m'ont fait découvrir
c'est un monde de contrastes
c'est un monde de contrastes avec des
conséquences énormes sur ce que nous
vivons je touche la mobilité surtout sur
l'identité la culture et surtout sur
notre vie de manière générale et
peut-être ya des leçons qui va servir à
nous inspirer pour le futur c'est un
monde connecté
c'est un monde connecté le nord et le
sud
très différents j'ai appris par hugo que
le neuf trois se trouvent dans
l'hémisphère sud
jeanne est pauvre et que le nord est
riche et âgés aujourd'hui et surtout il
ya un chiffre en eau toujours hugo
facebook 2 milliards de personnes
connectées et on a vu que la
connectivité ce que ça peut bouleverser
les choses on a eu le printemps arabe
on a eu trois points naheulbeuk site ont
allégé les jeunes on a dit de ne pas pas
j'ai jeu d'enfant mais c'est un monde de
ville aujourd'hui un monde des villes ou
de nos jours les deux tiers habitent
déjà dans une ville sont urbanisés
déchets de la planète et ce monde là les
villes aujourd'hui occupe à la fois un
territoire une population une économie
supérieure à certains pays
par exemple si certaines de ces villes
je prends tokyo jusqu'à nagoya ses 80
millions de personnes
chengdu à tianjin pareil depuis
vancouver jusqu'à tijuana en passant par
san francisco los angeles
c'est extraordinaire le nom la
population si cette agglomération cet
ensemble se mettaient ensemble étaient
conviés au g20 il serait à la place de
l'argentine ou de l'indonésie
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur et
les villes aujourd'hui ont une économie
des fois supérieur à certains pays
ce qui veut dire que les villes sont
concurrentes au niveau international
entre elles et souvent dans le même pays
elles sont concurrentes
les exemples sont nombreux barcelone
madrid vous le voyez sydney melbourne
shanghai sydney sao paulo et rio
ces deux villes représentent les deux
tiers de l'économie une poésie
donc vous voyez un peu la puissance des
villes dans le monde de demain
c'est un monde de diversité et à chaque
voyage on a découvert la diversité
et cette diversité qu'on sait justement
pas ceux qui ont l'audace de partir de
partir pour le travail pour des raisons
de guerre et même aujourd'hui plus des
raisons climatiques
ils vont ils ont le das ils ont le rêve
le rêve d'un avenir meilleur demain et
ce rêve 300 millions par an le pote il
bouche ils s'en vont ils vont ailleurs
vers l'inconnu et il crée de la valeur
qu'ils créent de la valeur parce que
c'est des plus aventurier il crée de la
valeur pour rien que pour par l'argent
soit on appelle les re mi temps que ces
immigrés renvoie dans le pays
c'est de l'ordre de 500 milliards de
dollars par an pour le continent
africain seulement ça dépasse la somme
totale dépasse tout ce que l'aide
internationale
on voit en afrique les africains renvoie
plus chez eux que toute l'aide
internationale il crée de laval mais
c'est pas fini il crée de la valeur dans
les pays où ils habitent
forbes 40% des entreprises américains
les mieux cotées les plus performantes
sont créées par des immigrants ou des
fils d'immigrant steve jobs ce parent
syrien sud appartient 6e 2 go bull et
j'en passe et c'est un monde qui
continue à être mobile mais pour
d'autres raisons mobile des touristes
mobile des expats mobile des retraités
et mobiles des étudiants les touristes
un milliard 6 qui vont bouger qui bouge
déjà dans le monde tous les ans ils
viennent en plus maintenant de nouveaux
pays émergents chine n afrique 300
millions bouche d'un fruit des retraités
qui choisissent de vivre deux étaient
parents un été dans l'or et un été dans
le sud à l'île maurice en avoir beaucoup
français qui viennent en argentine on
voit des canadiens qui descendent dans
le sud
en été et ça continue les expats pour
d'autres raisons
ils veulent une vie meilleure une
qualité de vie une offre culturelle et
souvent aussi hélas où les raisons
fiscales et les étudiants ils vont pour
ajouter de la valeur encore une fois à
leur pays ou aux pays qui les
accueillent
il parle y reviennent y reviennent pas
mais ils font partie de la communauté
internationale et les flux des capitaux
c'est important ça rejoint le point de
ce que hugo a dit les gaffes
par exemple les gaffes à gogo amazon
facebook est un peu représente plus leur
économie que beaucoup de pays pour
donner un petit exemple amazon a voulu
sortie en dehors de 2,6 à tout pour
créer un deuxième siège aux etats unis
20 villes américaines se sont portées
candidates parce que hier cinquante
mille emplois à la clé elle était
candidate comme les jeux olympiques
c'est pour vous dire que le lendemain la
ville choisie
quel va être son poids dans la
discussion le maire de la ville avec le
patron d'amazon
les essais pour ça ne comptait pas trop
sur les gouvernements
il faut compter sur autre chose que ce
qui se passe et ça continue les
connexions dans la mer et dans l'air et
face à cette mondialisation à outrance
sans borne
l'homme a besoin de refuge et elle se
réfugie dans différentes régions
géographiques l'union européenne le
mercosur des accords nationaux qu'à apec
et c'est dans la religion des fois où
par lang la francophonie et ainsi de
suite pour retrouver ensemble une
identité commune et des valeurs communes
et pour se repositionner
du coup se crée une nouvelle géographie
une géographie j'attire votre attention
c'est un seul chiffre les frontières on
a les frontières se mesurant km et les
connexions se meslier en millions de
kilomètres mais ce train pense que les
murs c'est mieux la chine de son côté
créé la nouvelle route de la soie pour
connecter des gens je ne sais pas si
dans les différents ça va pas jouer en
faveur de l'un ou de l'autre est une
autre valeur et elle peut être très
française
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet bilbao
l'effet bilbao remonte à l'opéra de
sydney 1950 a à peu près un équipement
culturel dans une ville a transformé le
pays
c'est l'identité d'un pays si de l'opéra
de sydney et depuis on a eu beaucoup du
ghanam à bilbao vous l'avez reconnu à
bouleverser l'économie de cette ville 20
% de croissance en une année wimille
jobs en une année suivi le louvre abou
dhabi bakou le sentent aliyev et hong
kong
ils sont en train de construire un
district culturel avec 17 projets
culturels deux déjà en construction
l'opéra de jeu de canton et le deuxième
le musée du 21e siècle en marche
ils ont compris la culture ou la france
est un des pays très fort en culture est
non seulement un facteur d'identité mais
une puissance économique à venir demain
avec 29 millions de jobs déjà dernière
et 6 après tout ce regard on voit que ça
ça ne va pas si mal que ça tous
les critères que je cite qui sont là de
monsieur robert un auteur suédois
statistiques à la preuve démontre un
analphabétisme divisé par cinq
la santé amélioré de cinq fois
l'environnement sur les 178 pays qui ont
signé l'accord de paris 172 ont un
meilleur index de paume une pollution
maintenant c'est peut-être pas assez
mais c'est déjà la d6 sont là et encore
une fois je regrette que hugo disait en
fait la presse nous disent toujours
autre chose
depuis qu'elle a un ventre et a été
inventé il ya six siècles on n'a que des
mauvaises nouvelles pendant six siècles
des trains qui arrivent à l'heure ne
font jamais la une et que donc on est
obligé de voir les mauvaises nouvelles
pendant six siècles
c'est presque de l'ain fox comme on dit
du fait que deux essais de ça on
alimente toute notre réflexion
la france non plus n'est pas si mal
vous voyez les chiffres vous allez les
vérifier et l'afrique l'afrique dans
tout ça en fait c'est là où j'ai eu mes
meilleurs mais plus belle leçon de vie
l'afrique d'afrique des médias c'est ça
mais l'afrique c'est aussi ça l'afrique
c'est ça l'afrique de demain le
continent sera le premier continent
francophone 300 millions de personnes au
monde 61 de la population 93% du
smartphone et encore une fois c'est les
jeunes qui sont connectés et c'est le
continent le plus jeune en plus alors eu
la femme vous savez les petites choses
et pourquoi je vous dis tout ça j'ai
découvert lors de mes voyages une
passion une passion pour les villes j'ai
retrouvé dans le monde entier au
tadjikistan un endroit où il ya un lac
hélas dans ceux là qui a aucune forme de
vie même pas un poisson
rien 4000 mètres d'altitude deux degrés
en été et les gens vivent là et ils sont
heureux de vivre là pourquoi ils ont des
projets en plus donc ça c'est une leçon
de vie et l'afrique m'a apporté tous à
l'afrique m'a apporté tout ça pourquoi
parce que nous quand on est ici vous
vous avez besoin de quelque chose vous
le commander sur amazon là bas ils
inventent il invente pour toute chose le
livrer des pizzas a vendu son
application à fedex
l'éleveur de vaches anaérobie à une
application targuer les oreilles des
vaches pour retrouver la vache p as tu
plus les l'heure de la traite et cie la
vache est en mauvaise santé
vous n'avez pas d'argent m-pesa on en a
déjà parlé
le numéro un mondial de mp saint l'agent
mobile c'est le kenya le kenya est
numéro un mondial dans un continent 75
ou au centre des gens n'ont pas n'ont
pas de compte en banque et ils ont
trouvé la solution et ce qui est
intéressant de nos ce que l'afrique ne
va pas suivre le chemin niveau 1 au
niveau 2 niveau 3 il va passer direct
niveau 5
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait avec un peu
ça et c'est ce qu'ils vont faire dans
beaucoup d'endroits le rwanda vient de
créer le premier aérodrome un aéroport
de drones au monde pour livrer des
médicaments dans des régions reculées au
lieu de construire des routes où ça va
être plus difficile et plus coûteux il
passe directe au niveau 5
et c'est ce genre d'innovation parce que
ils sont dans la survie et la survie
vous le savez c'est la mère de toutes
les inventions
c'est la mère de la créativité c'est la
mère de l'innovation
ils veulent vendre leur production
ils ont des centrales de distribution
sur smartphone entre eux et ils
s'organisent et ce qui fait que la ville
a alors à vie redevient une plateforme
une plateforme où le talent
l'intelligence surtout l'intelligence du
coeur et non plus s'ajoute la
technologie poe de veigné elle-même un
laboratoire un laboratoire où toutes ces
choses là sont devienne possible parce
qu'on met en relation les bons réseaux
on crie on situ les problèmes qui a et
on trouve les solutions ensemble et les
financements ou les réaliser et
finalement donc la ville c'est cette
connexion ses connexions dynamique
cette plateforme qui nous permet à tout
le monde de travailler et surtout de
penser qu'on peut travailler en sang les
jeunes moi je suis de la génération ou
heureusement je me suis dit comme martin
luther king et non pas l'inversé j'ai eu
un cauchemar mais j'ai eu un rêve j'ai
mis un rêve c'est de voir les jeunes
prendre les choses en main et demain
fait du monde ce que vous vous êtes en
train de faire de la plus belle manière
mais un endroit meilleur
et pourquoi pour le peuple pour la
population
[Applaudissements]